the senior VP of officiating of the
National Football League I'll River on
kind enough to join us in person right
here on the rich eyes to show how are
you I'm great man happy to be here I'm
thrilled that you are here before we get
into everything so few opportunities to
ask an official about themselves
personally so how how did you ever get
involved in officiating we just heard
about you you you started officiating
games in South Florida youth sports and
whatever how did you get involved in
this to begin so after my illustrious
high school career for your older
audience I didn't have Howard
Schnellenberger or anybody like that
knocking at my door sure I want to stay
in the game so officiating was part of
it yeah and a friend of a friend of a
friend came to me and said let's go to a
clinic well what's a clinic I'm not a
doctor said uh no clinic football
officiating right and started
officiating Youth League games in South
Florida did that for a lot of years then
high school and then I was fortunate
enough for one day to someone and
someone in the college ranks a
supervisor Paul Schmidt back in the
Sequoia days won't even tell you what
that is about those are the major
independence in the South before the Big
East and stuff like that started working
there then got picked up by the Big East
and then uh Mike Pereira had a brain
aneurysm and brought me into the
National Football and now here you are
now here Pereira was the one who who
invited you
where was the culprit yes ok and so now
it's interesting how he's in a position
to critique your work in front of a
national televised audience oh yes
critique is an understatement business
oh my gosh the microscope is just if so
what was the last NFL game that you
officiated I had a playoff game rich in
2012 in Houston hmm ironically enough I
forgot who they played because you
really don't remember who plays whom
sure you just know that your focus for
157 plays and you don't even know score
right I know it was a playoff game and I
know it was in Houston I couldn't even
tell you who it was
I'm figure if I could just pinpoint that
but that might be a Jets Texans game I
could be that it could be I don't
remember who the opponent was it that
was intimate then that
when they pulled you and say let's let's
get you in the front office yes in
charge of all this or beginning to be in
charge of all that stuff right okay so
let's start where where were you during
the NFC Championship game physically I
was in a command center what we call the
art McNally gameday central and that's
rich where we have the ability to be in
communication in contact at the at any
given time at with any given stadium
overseas Mexico anywhere so I was in the
art McNally gameday central right and
now did you realize right then and there
just like it was a no you know what
moment right then in there yes you did
now can you get on the horn at that
point in time and just say to these guys
what what is going on right now we're is
that something that you did at that
point in time or no which question you
want me to answer first okay can you do
that now we can okay now you can yes so
at the time you could not at that point
in time at the time and when I say now
we can now under two minutes the replay
official or replay in New York and get
involved right back then we could not by
rule we could not I'm gonna answer your
second question yes I want to yes but by
rule we could not so we did not yeah cuz
by rule that's not a reviewable play it
was not at a time correct now you can
now we can under two minutes we can do
it from the both more New York now it's
time okay so let's walk through it here
so a play happens in rec like one
o'clock Eastern window of games on a
Sunday so it's one of let's say 10:00
and there's a flag on the play
for pass interference and now it's week
one and here comes your first challenge
in the history of the National Football
League for pass interference what
happens at that point in time do you
think it's gonna take that long for this
to happen it might happen in the Hall of
Fame Game okay yeah all right so let's
just say well I mean okay so it might
happen in the Hall of Fame Game
what what happens then if something like
that happens what happens let's walk our
listeners and viewers through all this
well rich that people think it's a new
rule it's not a new rule past
interference will be officiated the same
way it has been on the field for the
last many years
has not changed what has changed is now
that past interference is now reviewable
aspect of the play just like completing
complete a player stepping out of bounds
things like that so again the rule
hasn't changed this has just been added
as a reviewable aspect of the play so
when that situation occurs like any
other replay I put on the headset we
take a look at it we confer with the
replay official and the referee and then
we come to a decision and yes at the end
it's our decision in New York but we do
consult with both the replay official
and the referee and then within sixty
Seconds we make a decision and yay or
nay and we play football and what are
you looking for again there's there's
there's a couple of bullet points that
need to or boxes that need to be checked
in order to maintain the call as stands
or or or confirm the call a stack or put
one on the field if there hasn't been if
there's actually now a challenge to say
that should have been past interference
there wasn't a flag for it which is that
that's definitely new as we all know so
what happens
walk walk everybody through what needs
to be seen let's go to the replay
process and this is the same as it has
been for any reviewable aspect of the
play before hmm so we start with the
premise whether you agree or not that
the ruling on the field is correct
that's number one that's where we start
number two is your clear and obvious
visual evidence that the ruling on the
field can be reversed that it's
incorrect clear and obvious that's huge
I know there's been many other words
used but it's clear and obvious and
that's part of the review process and
then if there is then we reverse the
call but if there is not clear and
obvious and if I had a nickel for every
time I said that I wouldn't be sitting
here today right I'd be in the Bahamas
someplace right so clear and obvious
yeah
visual evidence visual evidence through
our network partners we are only privy
to what they have on TV so one o'clock
game mmm one o'clock game you have
anywhere from eight to ten twelve
cameras Sunday night Monday night
Thursday night 24 thirty thirty-two so
again we're only privy and we live and
die
with what
TV gives us our network partners give us
so when you go to an obvious so when you
think this a couple of the time here our
River on head of NFL refs here in the
Rich Eisen show so if you are going
you're going to this Fox Media symposium
the Fox Sports symposium same thing when
you do at the NFL Network and obviously
Fox does the are the ones who present
the Thursday Night Football games that
are also on NFL Network do you go when
you go to Fox when you go to NBC and CBS
ESPN do you go and find the producers
that sit in the truck and say hey when
there's a play like this for pass
interference
I need your replays up on the screen
right away especially knowing that some
other teams are going to try and quick
snap do you do you express that
specifically to broadcast teams yes yes
we elaborate on that and we say we're
only as good as you make us they have to
give us that information as quickly as
possible also in New York rich I will
pick up the phone or someone in our in
our in our aren't McNally gameday
central will pick up the phone and say
hey dump the bucket what does that mean
to give us everything you have on this
plate so you're calling you're calling
the truck oh yes there are times when we
pick up the phone and call the train
you're speaking to the head producer in
a television truck is the head of NFL
refs you are direct communication with
whoever answers the phone it might not
be the big news at the time but whoever
answers the phone okay and so the clear
and obvious part isn't that subjective
though now when it all comes down to it
that your view of what clear and obvious
might be different from a replay
official in the stadium's version of
clear and obvious like that's the like
what will constitute clear and obvious
so here's where we are cleared obvious
came about again because we go back to
instant replay and what the rule is and
the rule is clear and obvious now we've
taken as Dan Quinn said earlier by the
way kudos to Dan for setting me up and
making it so easy - okay Dan thank you
very much Nucky I appreciate that
yeah so clear and obvious we did our
tour the lack of a better term well we
visited 31 of 32 clubs this year and we
put on a demonstration just like a
little bit more elaborate than when we
did when we went to the seminar okay and
we got their opinion that's pretty
elaborate it is it is we got their
opinion we got their feedback and we
came to a standard and again that
standard of clear and obvious was set
through a lot of work a lot of people
saying here's what I think
here's what I don't like here's what I
like president's general managers owners
head coaches players officials legends
everybody had a say in how we got to
that standard
it wasn't me sitting up one day and say
ah here's clearance standard here's
clear and obvious no the standard was
set through listening through a lot more
people a lot more intelligent than I am
right saying here's where we want to go
with this the competition committee we
saw thousands of plays and that's how we
started the show we start we saw
thousands of plays and then we went on
tour through every single NFL club and
we got their opinion they're there their
concerns their buying to be able to come
up it with the standard where we are
today well here's our River on head of
NFL ruffs so then again and and getting
it consistent from stadium to stadium
game to game official to official how do
you do that I mean cuz again when you
came and showed all these plays the NFL
media group and you put it on us to give
us an idea of what's gonna go on for you
and your team and your crew in the
crucible of a 60 second snapshot of an
NFL game that the rest of the country is
watching we could not come to a
consensus is what's clear and obvious
you confident that you and your crew
will have that consensus this fall yes
rich and remember it's not the officials
on the field because I go back to saying
sure the way we rule on pass
interference has not changed sure over
the last few years we're talking about
17 individuals in a booth who have been
extensively trained and will continue to
be trained and now when there is a flag
on the ground remember it goes back to
New York so there's a couple of us
Russell York our vice president for
instant replay myself who ultimately
will look at the process speak to the
replay official in the referee and then
come to a decision so it's not 121 122
it boils down to 17 who send it to us in
New York and ultimately it's one of us
two in New York who after collaborating
with the referee and a replay official
come to a decision so what happens if
two such instances happen at the same
time there's two of us okay
they're talking Russell York and myself
antlers tool these are a contingency for
three at the same yes there is we always
have someone in there either
another vice-president or one of our
supervisors who's always in the room
just in case we go to three I can tell
you if cases the next question yes in
the last two or three years it's only
happened twice that's it we're never
been on three replays at one time we've
had situations where we've had to jump
and then after we make a decision we
don't stay for the administration but
the bond to twelve
first and ten whatever but we have not
had three L into time so there's a line
of succession plan
yes throwing on right here yes sir in
case it gets down to three and then as
always you know no I'm around I know
you're always on call I'm always
available I know and I'm sure Roger
Goodell is too if it push comes to shove
that's question head of NFL refs out
River on here then let's get to the the
ultimate crux of this is that what I
told you at the symposium what I have
said here as well is that when you open
up things for a replay everything that's
reviewable must be reviewed or is
available to be reviewed and so fans
want this in place to correct what
happened in the NFC Championship game
for never happening again and I'm sure
you feel obviously the same way but now
that this gets opened up to see whether
a defensive pass interference call was
either proper or not and you come back
and go well we can't tell on that one
but one thing we can tell is the
offensive pass interference that nobody
thought we were reviewing guess what we
just reviewed that and there's now a
flag for the offense or in certain cases
now an offsetting penalty and I think
fans are not prepared for that al so my
question for you is is how judicious are
you gonna be on on that front if you
season what are you gonna do this fall
on that front so we go back rich to
reviewable aspects of the play let me
give another example right now
quarterback rolls to the right there's a
pass downfield twenty yards we rule
incomplete mmm-hmm offensive coach
challenges and says to either referee
hey rich I want to take a look at that I
want to review it because I think that
was a completed pass great now we go
back and review the entire play as a
quarterback is rolling out he is being
tackled and just before the knee hits
the ground we
have to look at where the ball is
released or still his hands let's say as
we're reviewing that why because it's a
reviewable aspect of the play his knee
is down balls in his hand we don't even
look downfield the play is over we put
it down right there why am I giving you
this because now pass interference is a
reviewable aspect of the play so if you
challenge for whatever you want to
challenge in this case the example I
showed was for dpi yes the offensive
pass interference if it's clear and
obvious I go back to that term if it's
clear and obvious that there's a
reviewable aspect of the play that we
can look at in Reverse and in this case
it happens to be offensive pass
interference then we stop there and we
say ok we now have clear and obvious
visual evidence that there is a foul for
OPI offensive pass interference we put a
flag down now we looked at the defensive
pass interference and treat that one so
you go step by step and then you make a
decision the same way we went step by
step on the quarterbacks need going down
before we had the completion downfield
same way here reviewable aspects of the
plate well how about this al then let's
just use this same instance quarterbacks
rolling out makes a throw and it's
complete ok and it's complete and the
defensive coach says I think he was down
I think it was down and then so now he's
challenging that and it comes back that
yeah the guy wasn't down but as a matter
of fact the pass was complete because
the receiver pushed off so the coach
who's hoping that there's no play at all
now gets an offensive pass interference
penalty that's to his benefit can that
happen yes and I'll give you what
happened a couple of years ago there was
a coach that challenge we roll on the
field and this might come up later on a
conversation we roll in the field that
the runner was down at the half yard
line and then the ball was fumbled maybe
it went beyond the goal line and through
the end zone that's another conversation
so the coach the offensive coach
challenges and he says to the referee
hey rich he was not down before the
broke the plane we should have six
points he challenges we look at it we
rule that he was not down correct the
ball came loose crossed the goal line
through the end zone out of bounds
I'm setting you up you're rich guess
what happens there yes what happens
they're rich so I look I just happened I
understand that pin in that because I
just want to finish this conversation
you're I just want to finish this
conversation is that if the coach who
says hey I think that the guy was down
the quarterback was down and the
quarterback was not down but now you
sees that the the offensive receiver
pushed off so I get the benefit as a
coach the defensive coach of saying oh
okay his knee wasn't down but I do get
the offensive pass interference but the
reason why I initially challenge was
whether the knee was down I was wrong
about that do I get to still keep my
challenge do I get that correct
technically even though what I
specifically asked for was incorrect
what about that you win and you lose you
get to keep it but obviously there's
gonna be OPI against you but you win the
challenge a reviewable aspect of the
play the channel aspect of the play
because we reversed a reviewable aspect
of the play you win the challenge but
none of this was intended to happen the
only intent to happen was to prevent the
NFC Championship from happening again
you as you see what I'm saying like that
there's gonna be so many instances now
that this this is a reviewable play that
suddenly the reason why this was put
into place is now totally spun in a
different direction do you like this
well remember again you can equate it to
many other things but once you open up
replay yes and once you have a replay
set and we're looking at things right
every reviewable aspect now you're right
you take OPI and dpi and you can
challenge for something else and we can
bring that in but we can bring it in for
any other reviewable aspect of the plate
no one else really ID please so what
about removing OPI and dpi from the
bucket of plays that could be reviewed
anytime that you must only specifically
ask for that to be reviewed for to be
either overturned or put
on the field like like this just remove
this from the bucket if well everything
is reviewable that can be reviewed so
it's too bad because it seems to me that
we're totally getting out of the reason
why we did this in the first place out
what about that idea so you were in the
room we discussed it right no because
that was one of the things that was
discussed rich this was put through such
a process yeah with the competition
committee and everyone else and that's
one of the things that we talked about
really do we take OPI and DPI and put it
in a different box again each and have
different rules just as far as replay
that was discussed and why was that not
because at the end of the day we want to
be as consistent as possible with
everything we do including replay leave
it in there
with everything else remember it's a one
year it's a one year rule right so we
will come back we'll give them all kinds
of stats the competition committee will
sit down again and say where do we go
from here are now River on senior
vice-president of officiating let's get
to the other topic of discussion here
why in the world does a ball that gets
fumbled into the end zone and out of
bounds penalize the offense by loss of
possession and reward the defense with
the football why is that rule in place
out
remember the Tonight Show Johnny Carson
like to of course when Carnac was in
there and he said I have your answer
right here shirt pocket I have part of
your answer I wish I could see it but I
can't your my glasses would that help
yeah I mean I owns a little I think it
but I'm gonna give you some stats first
of all by the way I just offered an
actual referee my glasses Brockman that
actually an X referee ok ok so this has
happened how many plays you think are no
football season I'll give it I'll give
it five how does that sound
what about over 40,000 plays we have
40,000 slaves all it takes is one now
well hang on we have 40,000 plays yes
roughly during a season yes over the
last three season a little bit over
120,000 plays that has happened 17 times
the competition committee has looked at
it yes for years as a matter of fact in
2017
there was a big spike it happened eight
times Oh eight times that was huge that
was huge
time it's 17 times too many at times
that's what I'm saying is just all has
to happen all here all it has to happen
is once at the end of a Super Bowl and I
would proper to say there would be many
fans totally confused irate wondering
why certainly if the defense that has
awarded the ball and then the Super Bowl
and Lombardi Trophy has been on its
heels III and it also penalizes a player
for making an aggressive play to try and
score I can turn that around and say a
player reaches out and and the good
defender comes across the line of
scrimmage and the last hope he has is to
knock that ball out of his hands right
and then because they made a good
defensive play rich yes the ball went
over the goal line through the end zone
which the defense in the often still has
an opportunity to pick it up by the way
right and it rolls out of the ends or
either through the sideline or the in
line but the competition committee
seriously
yes bid look at it there was a lot of
discussion on it and they felt that they
did not want to make the rule change for
X amount of play because it's again
because it just doesn't happen that
often that's correct is the reason why
would you rather live with it what about
the idea that the the ball stays with
the offense but goes the reverse touch
back that the ball goes to the 20-yard
line so it's still a penalty when he got
right there so here in my notes one of
the things we discussed was give it back
to the office where they fumble hmm move
the ball back to the 15-yard line fall
of that was discussed it really was at
the end of the day the committee felt
let's leave it the way it is and at that
moment don't penalize a defense for a
good rider again I don't suspect that
you would know the rulebooks
entire origin but why is this what like
what's the concept behind
I know it's hallowed ground the end zone
is the house is hallowed ground yes it
is it's a touchdown when it's when you
get six points right I get all of that
but why should that be different than
the half yard line if the ball rolls out
at the half yard line the offense gets
it six more feet they lose it it doesn't
make any sense to me
well you just said it when you get into
the end zone it's utopia and now you
have to remember by rule and this is
where go to the rule
you always have to remember as an
official and when you're playing
football right how did the ball get into
the endzone
who put the ball into the endzone so in
this situation the offensive team put
the ball into the endzone and the ball
goes out of bounds in the endzone by
rule wiggle the other way I know but it
just again you want to be consistent
with everything and officiating but you
you officiate a game can wait
the the goal lines and then a totally
different way inside the goal lines and
I understand again you get six points
for a touchdown that that's the endzone
but why should the difference get the
football I just it it drives me nuts
17 times over the last hundred forty
thousand plays well first of all I think
you need therapy for all this but that's
a nice boy okay smart job I take it very
seriously but when you talk about being
consistent rich that's just it who put
the ball in the end zone right and when
you think about it the offensive team
put the ball in the end zone and then
the ball is loose now it belongs to the
defense they put the ball in the end
zone
who put the ball in the end zone and
again seriously we're being consistent
and that's the way they cut the
committee finally went to last one for
you has there been any serious
consideration or close to change spot
foul to the college rule 15 yards for
pass interference it was talked about
again this year rich it was every year
that I've sat with the committee yes
it's been talked about we give them
stats they look at the stats and they
say no let's leave it where it is but it
was talked about again this year what
are the stats that make them say let's
leave it the way it is well I don't have
them with me
I wish I would have known that no no I
understand but again it's generally what
generally it's not as bad as we think it
is most occur within 15 yards right not
beyond 15 yards however it's a huge foul
I mean we've had some that are 45 50
yard fouls it is huge and the committee
has looked at it long and hard for the
last several years and there's been
propositions and there's been motions by
different teams to change it but the
committee has felt that this is the best
way to go up time and then last one for
you give me the name of the head coach
who wore you out the most when you were
officiating rich you know they're all on
my Christmas list they all call me every
year to say hello and they all say thank
you and it's been a wonderful
relationship all time because and you're
not gonna get me to say a name because
he's still coaching the Nash
footballing no you gotta go through it I
did he might be back you never know
might be bad wore you out huh oh yeah
there's a couple of them that you know
we've had long conversations with okay
yeah I'll thanks again really this has
been hopefully is enlightening to
everybody at home or behind the wheels
of their car or what have you is it as
it was to me in the room when with the
NFL media group when you when you stop
by say I had a Fox for us when you see
him this weekend will do that's al River
on the head of NFL refereeing and you
can follow NFL officiating right on
Twitter that gives you put tweets out in
real time during games to explain what's
going on correct all right so at NFL
officiating on Twitter and at NFL
football ops for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
red TV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app